لكل طرف سياسي في تركيا اشاره يد ترمز
اليه وهذه الاشارات اصبحت متداوله في
الشارع بين الناس لنتعرف على بعض معانيها
[موسيقى]
فمثلا هذه الاشاره لا ترمز لشعار النصر
الشائع استخدامه عالميا بل لحزب العمال
كردستاني الذي تصنفه انكر تنظيما ارهابيا
واعتاد انصاره على استخدامها في مظاهراتهم
الممنوعه بينما يستخدم الرئيس اردوغان
اشاره الاصابع الاربعه والتي تعني امه
واحده علم واحد وطن واحد دوله واحده
الذئب الرمادي شعار يستخدمه القوميون
الاتراك بشكل رئيسي وفعله ممنوع في بعض
البلدان الاوروبيه وهو مقتبس من اسطوره
تركيه تدل على الذئب الاكبر الذي قاد
الاتراك للخروج من واد بوصل فيه القلب
ليست اشاره يستخدمها العشاق وحدهم هنا بل
لها ابعاد سياسيه كما الكلجدار اوغلو
المنافس الابرز لاردوغان اختار استخدامها
للدلاله على قرب ومحبه حزبه للناس لكن بعض
السياسيين يجدون صعوبه في فعلها
[موسيقى]
اما المرشح الرئاسي محرم انجا فيستخدم
اشاره الاصابع الثلاثه في اشاره الى مسار
ثالث بديل عن الحكومه والمعارضه الحاليه
[موسيقى]